en fait alexandre benalla et son ami
collègue de l'elysée de la république en
marche l'ancien gendarme vincent kraz on
part juré à de nombreuses reprises
devant le sénat notamment sur la sphère
du contrat russe puisque et l'un et
l'autre ont affirmé sous serment en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure que alexandre benalla n'avait
jamais été mêlé ni de près ni de loin
dans le contrat qui avait été signée du
temps où les deux travaillé à l'elysée
avec un oligarque proche de vladimir
poutine et bien c'est faux c'est faux
alexandre benalla et l'architecte du
contrat c'est lui qui est en relation
avec l'homme d'affaires français jean
louis a game over qui représente les
intérêts de l'oligarque dès le début de
l'an viii de ce nouveau contrat de
sécurité
c'est lui qui présente vincent kraz à la
société à qui on va faire sous-traiter
l'exécution sécuritaire du contrat est
une société qui s'appelle velours c'est
alexandre benalla qui va constituer
l'équipe de sécurité c'est lui qui va
négocier financièrement du temps de
l'élise le contrat va être signé en juin
alexandre viala est toujours à l'elysée
en juin 2018
il ya un premier versement de 294 mille
euros qui va être fait et là patatras
révélations du monde sur les violences
du 1er mai panique panique comme on
l'entend dans les enregistrements
révélés par mediapart et d'alexandre
benalla et de vincent kra ce que la
police puisse mettre la main sur le
contrat russe qu'il faut absolument
cacher alors on change le montage
financier ont créé une nouvelle société
qui est dirigé par qui ont sous main par
alexandre bédat la nouvelle mouture du
contrat un million d'euros 1 million
d'euros et puis quelques semaines plus
tard un nouveau contrat avec un autre
lit gars que russe qui d'après le trésor
américain fait partie de la poutine
liste 1 le trésor américain a établi une
putin liste des oligarques proche du
président russe
cet homme phare cad à madoff qui est
l'oligarque pour lequel travaille aussi
benalla fait partie de cette liste du
trésor américain et là alexandre benalla
touche une partie des fonds c'est un
contrat une fois de plus de 1 million
d'euros
il en touche 3 153 milles sur un compte
au maroc dans une société dont il est le
seul ayant droit économique est bien
devant les sénateurs
monsieur benalla droit dans ses bottes
dit qu'il n'avait rien à voir avec aucun
contrat russe c'est faux